100-foot robot go campaign
the active hitting a second ball without
a penalty is called a mulligan if you do
it once and think about doing it a
second time does that mean you have to
mold again ah yes hello mr. mayor it's
your old pal max here you remember me
max your buddy see him I gave me that
briefcase a long ago well I need your
help I'm putting on a reunion show for
my robot golf entertainment franchise
and I need a city to play in I was think
of all the great cities i visited and I
can't stop by thinking about how great
yours was of course this isn't a joke
I've definitely kept track of your city
on the grow even after the robot wars
now surely you're exaggerating we're
playing golf with hundred-foot robots
here some small water damage isn't going
to be a hurdle mayor I'll take no false
modesty we'll be playing golf when your
city tomorrow just sent out the warning
notices and naturally I expect two of
your finest local competitors and a
golfing celebrity no excuses ladies and
gentlemen I lined up our first round of
golf it's time to make golfing
television
that's right ladies and gentlemen I am
Max and it's time for the yes let's try
for far ruin your tour our first stop is
it to your favorite of mine oh they city
let's turn it over to the city special
guest hello and they forgotten fourth
even older brother Rory McIlroy what a
mayor of old bay city i welcome you to
this mildly damp golfing wonderland
while this anymore underwater than I
remember was charm mix it made it known
worldwide that ball is off to Dreamland
come to sleep on the fair
now are we
you're just tuning in this is 100-foot
robot golf and you probably should have
guessed that already max I think there's
been some kind of terrible mistake here
I'm playing against training robots
great golf Camila
what time is it it's dr o'clock let's
get down there i'm not sure if it was
supposed to be some kind of statement
but they did destroy a favor the ball is
landed in the lava sand and out oh no as
it's burning it's giving a thumbs up a
sad thumbs up as it sinks in all you
hate to see this hasta LaVista baby I
know I'm lying way to pitch
sahota parasol Camilla's ready to golf
I'm always of the opinion that apart
from the mine
you
I am being informed by my lawyers that I
need to point out that my surname is
back along with an e I am not at all
related to the famous pga tour guide eca
is a registered trademark of a medical
association limited and this is
absolutely not related to their very
high-priced lawyers in any way we've
come within spitting distance of the
whole if you can strip a prize your
pretty partner shooting off an approach
shot from the fairway let's see if we
can avoid the remnants of human
civilization that seemed to be away this
good shot camila sure Ken golf huh
you're getting [ __ ] butter all over the
chassis not happy max well a rolling
ball gathers no moss but that's not
gonna be an issue here Ryan Gosling cuz
that was a great drive Oh cousin the
ball has stopped in the sand it's become
the friend of hermit crabs now
that was a wonderful shot from Camilla
don't you think there's enough room in
here that fall out of the ocean bed he
asked for a putt and you delivered thank
you the putter put in their putts and
send the putter putter
you